bonsoir athènes elle ventura bonjour
pour vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le procès dont de
donald trump qui a débuté mais sans le
principal intéressé
cette stratégie de la chaise vide est ce
qu'elle peut être payante pour donald
trump
je ne sais pas si elle sera seyant pour
donald trump mais en fin de compte c'est
une lutte pour le contenu en public
les démocrates essaye de convaincre 17
sénateurs républicains de voter contre
donald trump de voter pour la
destitution
il pourrait réussir à en débaucher six
ou sept et je ne pense pas qu'il y aura
une restitution à à la fin de cette
procédure est ce que c'est une bonne
stratégie pour donald trump et bientôt
naître ne peut rien dire et ne peut pas
s'exprimer publiquement car il est banni
de réseaux sociaux et aux états unis
pas beaucoup parler dans le camp de
trump à part par le biais de ses avocats
qui explique que lui n'est plus
président donc ne peut pas être destitué
et justement tellement fait rare c'est
un procès qui pourrait durer une semaine
vous disiez donald trump présent dans
les médias autant de temps que va l'être
le président sortant aux yeux des
américains dans les médias puisqu'il a
été privé de parole dans les réseaux
sociaux
défendre je pense qu'il va surtout de
passer par ses avocats
mais si je connais bien donald trump et
on a appris à le connaître
il n'a pas peur de se précipiter ans il
en a l'occasion
donc il serait intéressant de voir s'il
va finir par s'exprimer une mare à lagos
où là où il est il serait intéressant de
voir s'il va effectivement s'exprimer au
cours de cette semaine le cours de cette
procédure combien de temps va-t-il
pouvoir rester muet et laisser ses
avocats parler pour lui alors on le
disait le procès s'est ouvert il ya à
peine une heure le dossier d'accusation
contre donald trump se fonde sur des
faits concrets et solide c'est ce
qu'elle déclarait l'élu et procureurs
démocrate jamie raskin en diffusant dès
l'ouverture de ce procès devant un sénat
un montage vidéo à charge
est-ce que ça laisse présager un procès
finalement peu équitable
si le procès car c'est un procès équipe
au procès politique qui on passe au
sénat dans le capital américain ne
figure à un biais de gauche et un biais
de droite on ne peut pas y échapper
ce qui va être difficile c'est de
prouver que donald trump et ses associés
savait que la foule ou souhaité que la
foule attaque que le capital comme ils
l'ont fait c'est au coeur de cette
institution at il incité à
l'insurrection at il incité ses
partisans à cette violence est ce que
les démocrates soit apprécié de prouver
c'est que donald trump a sciemment
incité cette foule à commettre de la
violence à déranger la transition
pacifique du pouvoir ce qui se déroulait
et bien sûr la défense va accueillez que
n'ont pas du tout été de toute façon je
me fais pas la destituer car il est le
président j'ai regardé les images qui
ont été diffusées on voit les événements
tels qu'ils se sont déroulés
on voit des des moments clés du discours
de donald trump et les exactions de la
foule c'est une mode vidéo très
convaincante pour les gens qui étaient
présents et ce qui ne l'était pas à
washington ce jour là et cela a rappelé
aux gens le chaos de cette journée ce
procès donc qui se déroule au sénat dans
le capital a été brisée dès le départ
car chaque parti a un pied inhérents ils
essayent de vendre une image différente
au peuple américain
alors néanmoins donald trump possède
encore de très nombreux soutiens dans le
pays est ce qu'on entend encore la voie
d'être en piste
bénéficie de beaucoup de soutien
effectivement aux états unis et ses
supporteurs attendent de voir ce qui va
arriver
donald trump dans cette image d'homme
sous le feu de la critique de cette
personne qu'on essaye d'écarter du
pouvoir quel que soit le résultat de ce
procès que l'été montre aster obtiennent
17 républicains afin de pouvoir destitué
véritablement donald trump
s'ils réussissent à percer là alors les
républicains du rêve à regarder voilà qu
athlète un martyr si ils ne réussissent
pas alors les échantillons et dont il
n'y avait pas assez de pauvreté tel
massacre de nacre les relations entre
donald trump et ses soutiens ne vont pas
être modifiée par ce procès qu'elle
qu'en soit le résultat
donald trump réussi à faire croire quel
que soit le résultat de ces événements
et bien si notre homme qui aura raison
naïma les sénateurs devront garder le
silence sous peine je suis d'être en
poison en prison' et on s'attend à quoi
au juste
dans ce procès
sorti de la procédure de la discussion
sexy mais crier déranger le cours du
procès si cela arrive alors les
personnes responsables vont occulter les
situations et jamais personne a été
emprisonné lors de l'histoire ce qu'il
faut savoir ce qui va se passer c'est la
météo
s'il n'y avait là bas a effectivement
été un peu plus dense
nous avons forcément avoir de grands
moments de rations je pense que les deux
parties veulent un résultat et je ne
sais pas si il y aurait encore des
moments de folie parce que cela serait
en fait je ne peux pas dire que cela
était possible
en tout cas je m'y attends pas et
j'espère que la procédure se fera dans
le calme et qu'on atteindra un résultat
dans les semaines à venir
on suivra ça on l'espère en tout cas
avec votre aide ventura correspondante
berthet america merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct depuis washington